on reproche plusieurs choses d'abord il
aurait donné des faveurs dans le cadre
des commissions de discipline ce qui est
totalement faux parce que il est pas le
seul à pouvoir décider d'accord ensuite
on lui reproche d'avoir octroyé plus de
douche que prévu déjà je trouve ça fou
on est en 2022 vous êtes détenus en
France vous pouvez pas prendre une
douche par jour c'est un peu de la
phobie quand même de douche que prévu
franchement non mais là
qualifier
l'état de la maison d'arrêt
ensuite il parle de parloir plus long ou
bien de laisser des téléphones en
cellule enfin c'est des choses qui sont
de toute façon pas de l'attribution d'un
directeur de maison d'arrêt il a pas la
possibilité de gérer tout ça alors ça se
passe à un autre niveau ça se passe à
quel niveau on va pas se mentir des
téléphones en maison d'arrêt il y en a
partout dans toutes les cellules et ça
arrange bien le personnel pénitentiaire
parce que tant qu'ils sont dans la
cellule au téléphone ils sont pas en
train de demander justement une douche
ou bien la possibilité de pouvoir
continuer ou demander une promenade en
tout cas
Ichy pas tant qu'ils ont le téléphone en
détention donc tout ça c'est passé sous
silence mais c'est certainement pas un
directeur de maison d'arrêt qui fait
rentrer un téléphone portable donc moi
je pense plutôt que ça se passe au
niveau des surveillants très souvent on
nous dit que ce sont les avocats vu la
façon dont on est fouillé à l'entrée à
la sortie je doute que ça puisse venir
des avocats et les parloirs familles
c'est pareil ils sont fouillés je pense
que vous le savez parfaitement il aurait
fouillé de l'argent en échange de faveur
est-ce que c'est vrai ça ou pas et si
vous voulez l'infraction c'est la
corruption il faut un pack de corruption
et aujourd'hui dans ce dossier déjà vous
avez qu'un seul des prévenus à qui les
reprochait d'avoir remis une somme
d'argent et cette somme d'argent elle
aurait été remise au moment était déjà
libre
donc il y a pas un pack de corruption
qui est antérieur c'est pas si j'ai plus
que trois douches je te donne 500 euros
des détenus à part le téléphone quels
sont pardon les plus fréquentes des
détenus à part le téléphone du téléphone
c'est ce qui revient tout le temps ouais
le téléphone va peut-être que Monsieur
Molly peut nous en dire quelque chose
il y a des remises d'enveloppes il y a
pour ce directeur un compte créditeur
avec énormément d'argent alors qu'il a
peu de dépenses donc il y a quand même
des charges madame un directeur de
maison d'arrêt ça touche entre 3000 et
5000 euros déjà c'est un sujet peut-être
qu'il faudrait revoir pareil pour la
rémunération des surveillants mais à
aucun moment dans ces comptes bancaires
en tout cas de ce qui est dit
publiquement à l'audience il y a des
sommes qui sont qui en inadéquation avec
ses revenus jamais jamais ça a été dit
vous avez pas un virement d'un seul
détenu à ce directeur de maison d'arrêt
sur son compte en banque alors justement
on a un Marco qui est avec nous merci
beaucoup ça te fait rire ouais parce que
la corruption elle est partout d'accord
je connais très bien le directeur qui
parle c'est un ami à moi qui a été
reproché d'avoir donné des sous et des
espèces mais se directeur là il a un
autre business c'est pour ça qu'il a
qu'il a d'oseille il a un autre business
au Maroc d'accord il fait son business
et en même temps il est directeurs
vérifié parce qu'il y a pas beaucoup
donc j'ai pas fait associé parce que si
loue des quoi
mais le problème c'est que la correction
existe vous parlez des surveillants les
surveillants les pauvres déjà même si on
a qu'ils en font rentrer c'est parce
qu'ils gagnent pas bien leur vie
d'accord et en plus de ça tu as dit les
avocats sont fouillis à l'entrée moi
j'ai fait passer tous mes téléphones par
les avocats donc j'ai jamais été votre
conseil
au directeur de la maison d'arrêt où il
est dit que certains détenus avaient la
possibilité de voir plusieurs avocats et
de les voir en même temps avec d'autres
détenus et de discuter non mais c'est ce
qui est dit dans le dossier mais en tout
cas c'est pas autorisé vous venez de le
dire
c'est parce que j'avais d'autres clients
et que on a été amené à se croiser point
barre d'abord attends d'abord il y a une
chose qu'il faut savoir c'est que le
carbone ça
excusez-moi je veux dire un mot vulgaire
je sais pas dire autrement ça a [ __ ]
tous les avocats
[Rires]
le problème c'est que les clients qui
parlent là qui sont fait attraper c'est
des gens que je connais très bien et ils
font tous partie du carbone quand on est
arrivé en prison n'importe qui voulait
nous avoir moi j'ai vu en prison pendant
5 ans peut-être 300 avocats que j'ai
pris tous les jours que je voyais des
nouveaux avocats les surveillants
n'importe qui voulait de l'oseille vous
les sacripez à au carbone ça veut dire
il y a eu tellement d'argent qui a été
dit c'est pour ça que les gens se sont
mélangés mais la corruption existe
partout alors comment ça se passe Marco
toi tu avais quoi
c'est-à-dire dis-nous un écran 80 cm non
mais comment tu l'as fait venir ça je
l'ai fait venir des livreurs c'est pour
moi
non mais c'est vrai quand tu as fait
venir parce que en prison tu as le droit
de commander à l'extérieur et puis il y
a des choses qui passent qui on n'a pas
le droit de passer d'accord et là
d'accord emplacement s'est passé et là
tu payes et tu passes tu me payes tu
payes non je veux pas les balancer
dans la vie
tu peux payer n'importe qui même les
avocats ils sont corrompus n'importe qui
et corrompu du moment que tu payes alors
arrêtez votre cinéma tous de dire nous
on n'est pas corrompu les les avocats
les premiers sont corrompus mais
pourquoi tu dis ça
n'importe
quoi
toi le téléphone tu l'as eu par un des
avocats moi mais tous mes téléphones ont
été par mes avocats d'accord euh
c'est quoi cette histoire de sandwich
entre côte sans du genre de code quand
mes avocats y passaient ils passent avec
un sandwich il ne sortait je mangeais au
parleur avocat ça me coûtait un billet
en plus ça me coûtait 700 balles en plus
un sandwich entre autres non je ferai
500 balles à l'aéroport
parler ici par les invocatoire
il était frais encore le sandwich
à traiter
non qu'on soit sérieux tu veux qu'on
soit sérieux
dans des conditions qui sont
tu veux défendre un client à toi tu veux
défendre que ta partie défend tout le
monde les surveillants non tu parles pas
tout le monde tu parles seulement de ton
client et ton directeur il y a une chose
qu'il faut savoir c'est que le début le
détenu souffre le surveillant souffre
les directeurs souffrent il y a du
bordel dans la prison quoi qu'il arrive
globale
par exemple j'avais une cellule de 42 m²
à la place de 9 m², mais en fait le
dossier qui se joue aujourd'hui c'est
exactement à cause de ce que vous êtes
en train de dire c'est parce que comme
vous voulez pas donner l'impression que
vous avez vécu des moments difficiles
toujours vous voulez vous faire mousser
et bah vous raconter ça un peu comme
dans les écoutes ou monsieur mimrand dit
que effectivement le grand luxe c'est
génial c'est pour aussi rassurer les
gens à l'extérieur pas du même sujet
j'ai pu souffrir j'ai pu souffrir en
prison
j'ai le droit de j'ai eu plein de potes
au placard je te dis la vérité moi il y
a un pote mais non mais il m'a dit il
m'a dit je mange ce que je voulais tous
les midi j'ai mangé tout ce que je
voulais on cantine en fait non non non
non il m'a dit pas comment aux
États-Unis ou en fait vous avez une
cantine et où tout le monde se réunit
des jeunesse halal sans rigoler mais non
mais oui
vous avez le droit par le biais de
l'aumônier je crois de la viande cachée
en prison les pauvres les prisonniers
cela compte pas d'argent ils souffrent
énormément alors comment vas-tu
tu as ou du Paypal ou à l'extérieur
ouais Caou du Paypal mais tu vois son
surveillant directeur n'importe qui moi
pour moi il n'y a pas de corruption tout
le monde se démerde comme on se démerde
on est en prison le problème qu'on est
c'est qu'on est dans un autre bled on
doit se surveiller on doit survivre on
doit amener pour manger on doit même à
l'époque bon là maintenant les plaques
sont on a le droit aux plaques à
chauffer on a le droit à une plaque on a
le droit avant l'utilisateur un
ventilateur comment tu veux te démerder
d'avoir quatre ventilateurs pour que ça
fasse une prime on a le droit à un
ventilateur il fait 35 degrés tu avais
quatre ventilateur toi j'en avais 8 non
jeu mais tu as ouvert un magasin quoi
tu l'achètes il y a des détenus qu'on
commande qu'ils en veulent pas il y a
des du Condes clim tu l'achètes tu
l'achètes autant à l'intérieur des à
l'intérieur de tout tu démerdes c'est
une des mères et comment alors moi pour
les téléspectateurs qui nous regardent
on est en direct 19h53 comment quand tu
arrives le premier jour en prison tu
commences à te démerder c'est des gars
qui des autres détenus qui disent voilà
tu vois il faut choisir sa prison
d'accord déjà Fred il faut pas y aller
pourquoi
il va falloir être tu fais une crise tu
es malade ta mort hein il y a des gens
qui sont là-bas tu peux pas les voir
c'est comme ça tu choisis donc qu'est-ce
qui est tombé celui-là
on dirait un premier de la classe qui
sort d'essaye de il y a une chose que je
vais te dire il y a des choses où tu as
raison et c'est vrai tout le monde
s'ouvre que ça soit les directeurs que
ça soit les surveillants les pauvres ils
ont peur des détenus les détenus sont
ont peur des détenus s'il y a tout un
abalgame et et c'est vrai tu dis quelque
chose un téléphone il faut pas qu'il
interdisent parce que un téléphone c'est
comme si tu vivais dehors tu appelles
sur internet tu appelles en FaceTime ta
famille tu as pas là le problème des
Palois famille prend les parloirs
famille bien sûr qu'on regarde dans les
par leur famille c'est horrible les
pauvres qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent faire
rentrer ils veulent faire rentrer que de
la bouffe d'accord tu en as qui font
rentrer des choses bon après ça me
regarde pas ces trucs là qui font
montrer parce que même moi ça m'écœure
mais le problème c'est que la bouffe
là-bas les gens mangent très mal
d'accord mais que ça soit les directeurs
les directrices les surveillants je te
ma parole que c'est vrai il souffre tous
c'est un combat quand tu dis trois
douches par semaine moi je l'ai eu ça
c'était même pas à 3 douches par semaine
c'était une douche par semaine on l'a eu
il fallait se laver à l'eau froide à
l'intérieur on avait des toilettes avec
un tuyau qui coulait pour se laver ça
veut dire que c'est Fred c'est horrible
c'est la prison la plus horrible
aujourd'hui dans toutes les prisons il y
a des douches dans la cellule d'accord
c'est bidon ça permet d'appeler
un système
ah ouais je vais t'appeler là je veux
bosser t'inquiète pas on nous écoute
portable façon il marche pas les
téléphones qui sont ils sont tous cassés
c'est utile puisque les nouvelles
prisons ont mis en place dans la cellule
à la fois à la douche et à la fois le
téléphone et là l'objet de ce dossier
c'est de dire ce que
un écran plasma téléphone il mangeait
à votre enfant ouais c'est à dire un
jour vous leviez le matin vous diriez
j'ai envie de manger pâtes aux merguez
c'est pas ton merguez des pâtes au
merguez des pâtes au saumon je suis pas
très compliqué comme vous les faisiez
vous je les faisais moi non je les
faisais rentrer
un œuf d'accord
prends prends prends par exemple Genève
j'étais en prison à Genève tu commandes
et on te lit par comment ça s'appelle
le truc là on te livre réellement sur
place ici en France il y a pas ça mais
en France tu te démerdes autrement
d'accord c'est c'est la jungle que tu
dois vivre mais la corruption existe
partout madame l'avocate existe partout
chez vous chez les politiciens chez
n'importe qui elle existe du moment que
tu as la somme tout se paye dans sa vie
dans la vie et quoi qu'il arrive il y a
des sommes comme le refuse pas vous en
êtes pris vous les avez faites et vous
avez pu payer personne pour pas les
faire
c'est pas con
les années de prison que vous avez fait
vous avez pu payer personne pour pas les
faire d'accord je dois répondre
[Rires]
maintenant je vais te le dire parce que
tu me fais sortir de mes Gong si la
droite serait resté au pouvoir j'aurais
pas été en prison parce que c'est la
gauche qui est passé c'est pour ça que
c'est en prison et n'oublie pas que le
bordel que j'ai fait
s'il m'amène pas en prison qu'est-ce qui
se passe après c'est un cirque t'as vu
le bordel que j'ai fait avant d'aller en
prison et avant d'aller être sur enquête
j'ai fait un bordel je me suis fait
remarquer comme jamais c'est quoi de
dépenser de 300 millions d'euros en 5
ans le bordel
vous fassiez pas un jour de prison parce
que pour moi infraction financière
réponse financière au final vous avez
fait X années de prison qui ont coûté de
l'argent à la société l'argent a jamais
été récupéré et ça servi à quoi bah pas
grand chose
je sais que tu es gaucher
voilà parce que je ne vois pas l'utilité
de mettre les gens en prison pour des
infractions financières ça ça c'est ce
que je fais ça je t'aime
quelque chose vous allez en prison je
veux te dire une vraie exclusivité et là
je vais te la donner devant tout le
monde je la donne pour toi chérie moi
j'ai l'argent pour rembourser l'état
j'ai l'impression
tu vas me laisser parler
je te dis j'ai l'argent pour rembourser
mais j'ai un problème j'ai ils m'ont à
peu près pris pour 52 millions
d'affaires et d'appartements et de
monter tout ça ils veulent pas me
déduire donc là est-ce que je paye ou je
paye pas m'a demandé à votre dernière
avocat la semaine dernière
quoi qu'il arrive je paierai ma dette
parce que j'ai donné l'honneur et du
respect vous l'avez payé en allant en
prison monsieur Molly moi j'aurais
préféré que vous payez lorsque vous avez
pris dis-moi que vous n'aviez pas en
prison dis-moi que je garde l'oseille je
le garde c'est pas juste
la détention mais en revanche vous
pouvez pas dire que du coup vous avez
entièrement payé vos dettes à la société
moi j'ai payé
à toi
je crois que je comprends pas
j'ai fabriqué de la TVA
il est malade c'est nous qui payons les
prisons voilà nous mais qui qu'est-ce
que je t'appelle tu n'es qu'un même pas
tes impôts toi
[Applaudissements]
tu l'as déjà fait avec de Chavan ça va
vérité
tu veux que je te dis quelque chose le
problème que tu as c'est que toi tu as
raison sur tout ce que tu dis d'accord
mais moi je sais que personne va m'aider
donc quoi qu'il arrive je vais aller
chercher mon pognon moi j'ai pas raison
mais si tu as raison parce que tu dis
que tu as pas volé d'impôts français si
tu as volé des enfants
que je le répète emprunter de la TVA
maintenant faut la rendre ok
mais on va faire autre chose à ton avis
maintenant tu vas arrêter tout ça parce
que je vais te parler je vais te le dire
d'accord j'étais en prison pour 300
millions d'euros j'ai fabriqué un
milliard 600 millions d'euros de quoi
j'ai fabriqué un milliard 60000 ok
comment bah du chiffre d'affaires pour
faire les 300000 donc tu as les preuves
de tout ça mais j'ai pas mais tu peux
pas voler moi je peux pas
voler 200000 €
je répète l'histoire j'ai été seul j'ai
été seul à avoir été en prison
moi je pense que j'étais en prison 8 ans
en prison ils ont mis un homme d'accord
pour rien sans raison 7 ans je te
demande rien
vol
e
monsieur te dit mais tu as compris
pourquoi je gagne de l'argent c'est
grâce à vous comprenez rien
il faut vous parler
de carnet pas fait tout tout seul on ne
peut pas
aller ailleurs Monsieur le mec il a pas
dedans il a 22 ans il te dit j'ai 80
millions alors le banquier ne pose pas
de question c'est même pas parler le mec
ça veut dire quoi c'est ça que je suis
en train de te faire comprendre j'ai
compris c'est ça veut dire tout le monde
a touché
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
donc tu disais il y a un instant Marco
que tu étais le seul à avoir été en
prison mais que tout le monde avait
mangé tout le monde a mangé dans mon
affaire des avocats manger leurs têtes
c'est comme ils étaient avocats quand
j'allais en prison il venait à 9h du
matin il m'attendait
je suis un super avocat voilà c'est
gratuit au début tout est gratuit tout
est beau tout est ici mais après ça
coûte des millions ça coûte des 50 000
de 200000 des 300000 j'ai même payé des
avocats 500.000 euros moi et des gros
avocats ça veut dire que le carbone a
rendu fou tout le monde je connais le
directeur qui parle madame je te le
promets que c'est vrai c'est que ça
gentillesse ben c'est pas de l'argent il
s'est fait avoir par sa gentillesse et
non pas par l'argent
je les connais tous les détenus ils sont
un peu comme moi ils en bas de bien car
en vrai donc j'ai l'impression qu'il
était très aimé parler tout le monde
même moi je l'aime moi je l'aime j'ai
passé en 2004 en prison
et ils veulent que tout le monde se
calme il est très près
c'était de ce qui ressort je le dis
après j'ai pas donné mon avis c'est que
c'était un directeur prison qui en fait
a rongé cette voilà il était voilà bon
normalement c'est trois douches par
lourd allez faites une douche de plus
c'était il était pas voilà dans le sur
le règlement c'était quelqu'un qui était
assez humain et voilà il y avait un
problème excuse-moi de te couper il y a
eu un problème entre le se directeur là
et les chefs de division d'accord comme
les chefs de division le directeur il
disait bon il va faire la douche le chef
de Vision il disait oh c'est moi qui
commande ici et l'autre il disait oh
c'est moi le directeur c'est encore
comme tout le monde c'est une histoire
de d'orgueil d'orgueil
moi je suis le directeur occupe-toi de
ta paperasse ego et moi je me voilà
dégoût et moi je m'occupe des détenus
c'est comme ça qu'il y a eu des balances
dont il a touché l'autre il a pas touché
ce qui est intéressant c'est ce que vous
avez dit tout à l'heure et sur le
traitement judiciaire vous avez dit les
personnes impliquées sont des personnes
pour certains pas tous qui ont été un
peu médiatisés soit par la taxe carbone
que par l'attaque carbone
chez la vérité et donc ce que je me dis
c'est que j'essaye de regarder par
rapport aux autres affaires de
corruption qui a pu avoir le traitement
qui a été réservé à ses autres affaires
par justice et je pense notamment à
directeur de maison d'arrêt qui est
soi-disant tombé amoureux de cette femme
qui était là pas dans le dossier Dylan
Halimi
monstrueux
qui a du coup octroyé énormément de
faveurs à cette jeune détenue qui a
commis quand même quelque chose
de prison alors que Monsieur
elle dit justement il a il a il a il a
il a été avec elle
il a été condamné à deux ans mais à une
peine ferme qui était aménageable alors
que là Monsieur Elka il a fait 8 mois de
détention provisoire
qui est pas grave il m'a fait des
faveurs je n'ai jamais payé le directeur
et pour demain mais attention ouais moi
je dis tout bah oui attention je
l'embrouillais peut-être un peu trop je
lui disais j'ai des j'ai des
connaissances je vais te faire monter tu
vas passer grand directeur facile ça
d'accord oui en vérité ça vaut rien tu
as compris donc voilà t'embrouille tout
le monde
je suis là il croit prendre ta place tu
te rends compte
que c'est mort tu as compris ce que je
voulais dire
c'est compris c'est bien de l'entendre
dire là que d'embrouiller des directeurs
ça ne sert à rien de le dire parce que
quand on entend Marco on a l'impression
qu'en prison tu peux tout faire on peut
y aller demain parce que tu peux
commander des plasma tu peux commander
des sandwich internet tu peux commander
tout ce que tu veux si tu as de l'argent
mais faut pas dire aux gens que si tu as
de l'argent la prison c'est bien entendu
dire que les directeurs on peut pas
comprendre un directeur de personne
maintenant d'abord
il vient pas dans ta cellule un
directeur d'abord quand il te voit un
directeur il s'appelle dans son bureau
et ils sont jamais seuls pour pas avoir
de ce problème de corruption ils sont
toujours deux ou trois il y a une
particularité qui fait que c'est une des
seules maisons d'arrêt ou en fait non
parloir avocat à nous sont au sein de la
détention quand on va à fleurir on a une
aile qui est réservée au Parlement
avocat donc on croise pas les détenus
moi quand j'allais à Fresnes bah je
croisais les détenus qui allaient à la
promenade si j'en connais c'est un même
si j'étais plus en avocat à ce moment-là
parce que je suis plus collaboratrice
d'un tel et que je le vois je vais le
dire bonjour je suis humaine donc
normalement on est pas française parler
alors mais aucun moment le directeur
intervient à ce moment-là c'est juste
c'est la géographie de la maison d'arrêt
qui fait ça très dur moi j'ai une
question pour Marco vous appréciez et je
m'aperçois que vous êtes un menteur vous
avez dit là pour la première fois et
c'était norme que vous avez l'argent
c'est à dire que vous avez planqué
l'argent de la taxe carbone donc si vous
êtes un homme dites-nous combien et où
Marco Molly
[Rires]
e désolé de répéter tu as lu le livre de
la cavale donc tu es pas bête mais je
vais te poser une question
de poser une seule question qui va me
répondre ok ce matin non mais c'est la
première fois où tu es
nettement
alors je réponds je me suis douché
maintenant répondre alors je n'ai pas
planqué l'argent si tu viens de le dire
je n'ai pas planqué l'argent j'ai
l'argent j'ai fabriqué l'argent en deux
ans j'avais promis qu'en deux ans je
remboursais ma dette et je le dis haut
et fort si jamais demain et je le ferai
là le débat il y a un conseiller Lola il
est où le pognon
oui vas-y calme-toi mon cul tu vas faire
un marque au Molly calme-toi
tu as pas pris avec moi qui fait ça
le pognon gelé
pardon le pognon gelé caché mais je l'ai
fabriqué en travaillant je veux le payer
à l'état français maintenant c'est la
cacher où il va pas te le dire tu l'as
caché au Maroc dis-le tu l'as caché au
Maroc ton pognon pourquoi tu le dis pas
je suis marocain tu as caché le pognon
tu as caché des centaines de millions au
Maroc qui proviennent de la taxe carbone
à l'étranger où j'ai gagné 310 millions
en 2 ans maintenant je te le dis je le
dis à la France s'ils veulent l'argent
qui vient de faire des comptes avec moi
ils m'ont pris que 57 millions de puces
ils ne veulent pas les déduire ils
veulent la somme totale alors je te le
dis je te le répète s'il te plaît je
t'en supplie écoute-moi pour une fois tu
as gagné 310 millions deux ans à la
bourse mais que tu te fous de la gueule
de qui mais personne gagne 310 millions
deux ans à la Bourse en ce moment arrête
c'est l'argent de la taxe carbone que tu
as planqué et non mais regarde-moi
alors laisse-moi parler vas-y où est
l'argent je vais te donner
[Rires]
je vais te donner ma société coton en
bourse aujourd'hui les banques grâce à
Dieu m'ont donné plus de 600 millions
d'euros 600 millions d'euros
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tu veux parler
on lui a dit tu veux parler là ou pas ok
parce que là tu es en train de rouler
alors je t'explique lui il est venu me
voir au café il est venu me voir comme
ça il m'a dit Marco je te fais ce que tu
veux pour un million je te jure amis
mon passeport non alors s'il te plaît
joue-le jour-le tu m'as pas dit que tu
es prêt tu me tues mais gérant et il y a
pas de toi il y a l'autre comment il
s'appelle l'autre là soit disant beau
gosse là avec toi en vacances là
tu as caché dans son froc
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
va me chercher une enveloppe là-bas
parce qu'il se fait pas remarquer lui
c'est Jean-Michel maire elle est belle
personne
forcément là là ça va être compliqué on
est en direct il est 20h19
il y a des révélations
tout le monde même ici même ici que tu
vois il y a que toi qu'on peut pas
embrouiller parce que tu es bourré
[Rires]
donc
tu peux n'importe qui peut travailler
pour moi c'est vrai c'est juste la somme
pour chaque la corruption elle est
partie si je lui dis va voir si Cyril va
m'amener des papiers je veux ça je veux
ça je veux ça tu casses pas la tête tu
vois avec les volets c'est le prix qui
monte c'est tout c'est le prix
Daniel pour l'argent désolé désolé mais
pas transporter n'importe quoi et
Mathieu je pense qu'ils transit
est-ce que tu l'as déjà fait de quoi
qu'est-ce que je viens de dire non non
je n'ai jamais
dit tout le monde ici toi qui parle
est-ce que parce que tu
es en train de battre
moi je suis là il est pas facile
celui-là
il est pas compliqué
c'est pas possible alors je vous
remercie Carol Olivia monteneau d'avoir
été avec nous on va se compenser les
spectateurs tiens oui 83 % non à 16 %
les gens apparemment vous entendu oui
quoi oui
83 % oui corrompus selon vous
ça va
[Rires]